[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à six semaines
et qu'il ap
ah ah
depuis tout à l'heure je vais faire un
truc d'enfants non c'était une bêtise
quoi vraiment ca mais je crève d'envié
nos médecins dont le départ est dû tout
arrêter là oui non regardez non parce
qu'il faut qu'on leur 11,6 va être noir
oui mais justement je sens que ça va
vous mettre un tout petit peu dans la
merde j'ai un tout petit loyer de voix
gisèle au delà s'il vous plaît
j'appelle la police
vous voyez j'ai chaud mais il sent le
brûlé ce qui est étrange parce que les
qu'est ce que c'est que cette matière
j'ai jamais su du clan et cuivres et il
y ait une dalle et il faut partir les
couvre le donc voilà c'est made in
france et qu'il faut à peu près de
quinze heures pour fabriquer une
statuette pour la petite histoire ferval
a juste le temps de la cérémonie
est
venu vivre il y
[Musique]
pas
[Rires]
[Musique]
les dix ou quinze jours moi j'hésite
entre salah
et ça enfin je ne sais pas comment je
vais faire la couleur rouge appelle un
peu plus que la jeune âge j'ai peut-être
prendre salle apprenait sur l'histoire
[Musique]
enfin attention non genou garage est
ouvert
quelle range rover j'ai plutôt vide to
go avec deux pneus crevés